Bellco is a nonprofit organization that
facilitates American companies in South
America all employees
lend me your full attention hey it's
Jesus your chance of survival increases
by following my orders
your task is simply this kill three of
your co-workers or we will kill six
others okay all the lines dead we need
to evacuate the floor hey come on it's a
joke
was doing this they're having a little
fun at our expense
Stage one commenced his head exploded
from the inside what when we start
working here at the tracer is sitting
the back of your heads
you must not remove the tag from your
body follow our directives or we will
detonate the explosive begin a melting
at home do you know what kind of metal
this is I don't really know we need to
discuss all our options we do not have
the right to take anything human lives
life time my wife and kids made me stage
to commence you don't need no more
weapons we need to work together to get
the hell out of here [ __ ]
in two minutes we want 30 of you dead if
30 of you are not dead we will end 60 of
your lives ourselves
three
the end of the day people are out for
themselves
you
all employees
lend me your full attention
you